here's what you have to understand about
asians they are racist like actually
racist a lot more than america or the eu
especially against other asians you know
because of wars and the pillaging that
came with it the japanese always trying
to take over china and the asian rivalry
that concerns us today is the hatred
resentment that simmers under the
surface between koreans and the japanese
they're always trying to one-up each
other see in the 90s japanese pop or
j-pop was in its golden age records were
selling in the millions people were
making a ton of money but there was a
huge problem with j-pop it never became
popular in the west it was isolated to
japan and the koreans took notice
during the 90s korean pop or k-pop was
just in its infancy and they took notice
of all these inefficiencies in the
japanese model j-pop was just not
marketable to westerners so they aimed
to outshine them not just in korea but
on the world stage to do this you have
to get creative see at the time you kind
of just had to wait and hope that a pop
star would just appear out then air but
that just takes too much time and is too
random there's no way you could build an
empire with just naturally born pop
stars so you realize that the only way
to make this business sustainable is to
create the pop stars yourself to groom
them from scratch into a marketable
sensation
and you didn't just want one or two no
to show japan and the rest of the world
just how superior korean culture is you
would need an army of k-pop stars and to
create an army of k-pop stars you
couldn't view them as human anymore
k-pop stars were now a product and to
create a product you need a well-oiled
factory a heartless brutal assembly line
where innocent kids go in and out came
obedient marketable replaceable k-pop
stars and the ones that don't make the
cut that don't pass the quality control
well those faulty products are thrown
into the trash
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime in my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
starting right now we're picking a
random instagram follower every single
week to win you just have to be
following me at jaketren just got this
new handle and you're automatically
entered watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
this is the ruthless business of k-pop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you become an overnight kpop
sensation and you suddenly start making
a ton of money you might find yourself
in the same problem that many of us
americans face all of us need loans to
make big purchases like houses and cars
but you can only get a loan if you have
good credits but in order to have good
credit you need a credit card but to get
a credit card you need good credits do
you see the issue here this chicken and
egg thing used to be a really big
problem but now we have extra extra is
the world's first debit card that helps
you build your credits yes you heard
that right a debit card that helps you
build your credits you can even earn
reward points just like a real credit
card but minus the credit checks
interest and risk of getting in debts
here's how it works first you go to the
link below you sign up for extra and
link your bank accounts and once you're
signed up you'll get your extra card in
the mail whenever you pay for something
you would swipe your extra card just
like you would with any other card and
extra would then cover your purchase
then they'll also pay themselves back
the next business day at the end of each
month all those purchases you made are
then reported back to the credit bureaus
as creditworthy purchases building up
your credit with everything you buy and
you get all of this without having to
make a deposit or go through a credit
check so if you're ready to join over
125 000 people working on their credit
with extra pause the video right now and
go to extra.apps.jam with the link below
that's extra.app jam with the link below
thanks to extra for sponsoring this
video
to make k-pop a money-making and
influence spreading machine you have to
make it unique distinct from things like
j-pop first k-pop groups are large they
can have anywhere from 4 to over 20
performers in the same group like
everything in the industry this was done
on purpose more members would increase
the odds that fans would like one of the
stars it gives fans a variety to choose
from one of the shortcomings of j-pop is
that it's 100 japanese making it hard
for westerners to get into k-pop on the
other hand is known for blending korean
and western styles together making it
much more marketable and accessible
overseas
once the internet and things like
youtube came along j-pop labels were
geo-restricting their music videos to
only asia they banned the use of their
album artwork online they would even pay
while fold like music videos to make
more money up front imagine only getting
to watch only half of a music video on
youtube
the kpop industry took notice and turned
all of this up on his head
then of course there's the assembly line
of molding a k-pop star and that's what
really sets k-pop apart from every other
music genre and industry
[Music]
at the start of the k-pop pipeline are
agents in charge of recruiting trading
marketing and more they're called agents
but really they're product designers
which brings us to step number one look
for naive kids that have that little
spark in their eyes that also fit the
south korean beauty standard then tall
and feminine looking with adolescent
facial features these are the qualities
we want in both male and female stars
once we pick the boys and girls with
potential that's when the process really
starts
step number two have the kids sign a
slave contract that lasts until they're
adults some haters will call it a
literal slave contract but we like to
call it good business yeah sure many
kpop trainees start training as young as
nine years old but that's the whole
point it's the best time for them to
sign their rights away and it's when
they're most motivated
today the contract only lasts a maximum
of seven years but just a few years ago
the typical trainee idol contract could
last up to 13 years
lauren and many of the trainees have
been alive when they signed
during the contract length trainees and
stars are prohibited from just about
everything that makes life enjoyable
they can't eat what they want to they
can't do what they want they can't look
the way they want or even sleep the way
they want you get to control absolutely
everything about their life that is the
price of just attempting to become a
k-pop star the contracts are also
designed in a way to ensure that the
entertainment agency makes the most
money
trainees must pay back the money spent
on training them before they get to make
a single penny so at the age of 9 years
old they've already dug themselves into
a lot of debts and even then there's no
guarantee they'll debut as a k-pop star
whether they become famous or not they
still have to repay their debts
on top of that we're the ones entitled
to 60 to 70 percent of the profits while
the artists generally only make 30 to 40
and yet expenses are split 50 50. stars
must use that 30 to 40 percent to pay us
back the training costs so we're
basically guaranteed a return on our
investment while the slaves put their
entire lives on the line a fair trade if
you ask me
many of the slaves end up taking out
loans to cover their living expenses for
the years that they're not getting paid
it's a vicious cycle that makes it very
hard for slaves to make money even if
they get famous kinda like student loans
in the us but on steroids
from the very beginning we outline the
contract to make sure that no matter
what happens or how successful the
artist gets we are profiting the most
and finally step number three they set
out to spend the next three to five
years of their lives in brutal training
but this isn't just your average after
school activity kpop training is intense
and severe imagine military boot camp
but for turning you into a pop star
immediately the training camps force
trainees to change the way they act and
think trainees are put on extreme diets
and exercise routines many training
camps require trainees to be under a
specific weight
trainees often don't even have time to
sleep
and we also give trainees a helpful
nudge to look their best by shaming them
into getting plastic surgery and body
modifications after all this time in
pain only around 10 percent of trainees
will ever get to debut as a k-pop star
and for those who are lucky enough to
get placed in a k-pop group things only
get worse
[Music]
the harsh conditions that trainees live
under don't just go away when they
become stars
now they're actually making money for us
so if anything we need them under even
more control we gotta protect our
investments k-pop stars are expected to
stay as thin as possible many of them
use the infamous paper cup diet to lose
weight it involves eating only 9 paper
cups full of grains fruits and veggies
per day like the little cups you get at
a water cooler their gym routines also
get very extreme when they practice
dance routines stars wear 4 kilogram
sandbags tied around their feet
which is supposed to make them look
lighter when they perform on stage and
they get no breaks
[Music]
we make stars bleach their skin remove
parts of their jaw and undergo whatever
other procedures they need to look just
right
does this kind of stuff cause many kpop
stars to develop eating disorders and
encourage unrealistic high beauty
expectations yep
anyways we also have to make sure that
stars have zero life outside of being a
k-pop sensation stars aren't allowed to
date because they need to seem as
accessible as possible to their fans we
gotta keep the teenage girls dreaming
this is also why k-pop groups are all
male or female we don't want fans to
think that members of the group could be
dating each other stars who haven't had
their big break are not allowed to spend
time with their family or friends
to make sure they're following our rules
we take away their phones so they can't
contact anyone we don't know about
and the best part is by this point it's
too late for them to turn back even if
they wanted to there's nowhere for them
to go until they repay us back for their
training
so we groom them into becoming the
perfect little k-pop stars and send them
off to make us billions of dollars while
spreading korean influence all over the
world it's a win-win right
[Applause]
[Music]
k-pop has developed into a massive
international business that's totally
transformed south korea's economy and
influence today k-pop music videos on
youtube have accumulated 86 billion
views
just the major k-pop boy band bts alone
increased south korea's gdp by 5 billion
dollars that means just 5.5 bts boy
bands add up to the equivalent of the
entire north korean economy
bts is so successful that the twitter
had four times more engagement than
president donald trump's account in 2019
the group even acts as a political
ambassador for south korea in 2018 they
perform for kim jong-un although the
north korean leader has since changed
his mind about the music genre the south
korean government has praised bts and
other successful k-pop groups for quote
getting foreigners excited about korean
culture end quotes
so everything is going according to plan
for music labels in the country
one study estimated that for every one
dollar spent on the k-pop industry the
korean government gets five dollars back
but the problem with treating k-pop
stars like their products is that
they're not objects they're people and
when a person is pushed to their edge
from years of backbreaking work and
criticism being held hostage financially
and kept from their family some of them
break
sadly k-pop stars breaking under
pressure is becoming a trend in 2019 a
well-known k-pop star named sully was
found dead in her home by her manager
later it was confirmed that sully had
killed herself she was only 25 years old
sully was one of the few k-pop artists
that tried to rebel against the
industry's rules she had a boyfriend she
spoke candidly about her mental health
and she even put her career on hold when
she was struggling emotionally in 2014
all these things were looked down upon
by the k-pop industry which led to
die-hard fans bullying her relentlessly
on the internets
[Music]
eventually it all became too much and
for solely there was only one way out
there are many stories of k-pop stars
like sully who killed themselves after
years in the industry only two years
earlier a singer named kim jong-hun
committed suicide in his suicide note he
said quotes it wasn't my path to be
world famous it's a miracle that i've
endured all this time end quotes
at least seven major k-pop stars had
committed suicide by 2019 and it's
probably only gonna get worse
[Music]
hope you guys enjoyed the video i am
probably banned in both north and south
korea now so subscribe to the channel so
it wasn't all for nothing but joseph
said this is one of the biggest channels
on youtube for documentaries on money
power war and crime we made multiple
documentaries just like this one every
single week for free so click that
subscribe button below and if you want
longer documentaries that are too
controversial to post publicly our two
last private documentaries already got
age restricted our newest one is on the
american queue in iran that set up a
chain reaction of a bunch of bad stuff
happening around the world all thanks to
one american coup really proud of that
one it's already age-restricted and you
can watch it right now by clicking that
join button below there's a refund
policy too so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining and we will
refund you for that first month it is
only the first month that you're gonna
get refunded because a few bad apples
decided to abuse this refund policy you
can follow me on instagram for a chance
to 1 000 at jake tran we've had multiple
winners already that we sent the money
to and that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you